it's time to go back in time for another
edition of
big dick history
how is this doing by the way this big
dick history we stumbled upon it
the way one stumbles upon a large penis
in life
and then suddenly you guys are telling
me we have to do it more and we have to
do it again which leads me to believe
that there's been some kind of response
out there it's taking over the world oh
yeah
big dick history well it's big it's
making history
and it's a big dick i don't know i will
tell you i'll tell you this
it combines things that people are
fascinated by it's uh
history those history podcasts do very
well mm-hmm
yeah and then um penises
it's the only history i'll listen to i'm
gonna be honest with you i mean i know
you are really into like
dates and details but i'm just like how
big was the dick that was involved yeah
okay sorry well if this is something
that america wants
then it's our job to give it to them
that's right uh
so you're welcome i mean this can't bite
us in the ass
the bigger the dick the bigger the fall
but who cares we're gonna do
something today called big dick history
the quiz
are you ready yep okay just buzz in by
yelling your name if you know the answer
okay number one what historical figures
swang and wang was described by a time
magazine journalist in 1927
as a quote malt-treated strip of
buckskin
shoelace wait a minute can i hear the
question again
what historical figures swang and wang
was described by a time
magazine journalist in 1927 as a
malt-treated strip of buckskin
shoelace is it rasputin
napoleon prince albert or vladimir lenin
oh uh it would be i'm gonna say sona
yes sona lenin incorrect i'm gonna say
napoleon napoleon is correct
god damn it all right one point uh they
actually
claim to have napoleon's penis that's
right
the others would not be available for
inspection whereas i think napoleon's
would be my understanding is it's
actually like a book sellers
keep in mind a lot of this research is
rumor-based but
for our purposes who cares uh you know
it's not only
owned napoleon's penis by a bookseller
did you know this
it's used as a bookmark
yeah that explains a lot yeah when this
guy's reading 50 shades of gray and he
gets to a
he's tired and he wants to just turn in
for the night he puts napoleon's penis
uh into the book and shuts it yeah after
he uses it to floss his teeth okay next
question
oh what are you doing what did you do
how can you go too far on big dick
history
you know what you can and you just did
yeah you did it's an achievement using a
dick is floss
i think that's where we draw the line
for
big dick history well we had to find it
number two
actor gary cooper was nicknamed
the pennsylvania pipeline new york pork
old faithful or the montana mule
uh pennsylvania pipeline that's
incorrect no it's correct
no don't start this again this is a big
dick history
you have to lose graciously yeah just
try to lose graciously so
wait what was the question again i
thought we were asking what's the best
way to get
oil to pennsylvan to philadelphia no was
that the question
it's the pennsylvania pipeline it's not
oh yeah the montana mule yeah
sona what's your answer i i don't go
with money go with montana mule
and you'll win i don't i don't want to
go ahead yes if i do then i know that
you know go ahead
it's montana i'm gonna go with old
faithful actually it's montana mule
so nobody gets the point there oh yeah
but you know what i get a point for
telling sona
no you don't okay no you don't no
because i knew it was correct and then i
told sona
she refused to take it out of foolish
pride and she went down in flames
if you knew it why did you say the
pennsylvania one first
because i had a funny joke about how to
get to oil to to philadelphia that
doesn't make any sense you just had you
got it wrong
no you always said the second time so
your chances of getting it right the
second time were
better nope i always win go ahead you
did definitely didn't win that
was wrong so conan was wrong on that one
gourley okay thank you
conor o'brien's always right was the
original name of this podcast
you're giving big dick history a double
meaning on this podcast
okay number three let's edit that out
okay
athlete wilt chamberlain's big guy
was nicknamed the stilt big dipper
drill bit or the bazooka sona
sona i don't like can i say something
shouting out your name
you're winning and you're still somehow
a sore loser this is incredible
uh i'm gonna guess the stilt that's not
correct
come on all i have to do is guess conan
the remaining uh choices are
big dipper drill bit or the bazooka we
all
know it's uh the drill bit sorry it's
the big dipper
yeah i know you got it wrong conan i'm
not sure if you knew that no i
here's the thing i know the answers to
all of these but by appearing not to
know them i don't come across as someone
who's obsessed with penises
i should have known never to do a quiz
all right
okay number four most infuriating person
to do this with
there's no one worse oh i thought that
was the next question
number four juan baptista dos santos was
known for
a a forked schlong b
one main schlong with a tiny little
schlong coming out of it kind of like
how a xenomorph in the movie aliens has
one of those little things
c two separate working schlongs
or d the biggest schlong ever on record
sona yeah i'm gonna say uh double
schlong
the two separate working songs yes or
the one main separate working schlong
that's correct conan i got it right i
just
i know but sure did everyone notice that
she has a hard g and she went
that's what you wanted
and then i'm like i don't even want to
play when i hear schlong you want to you
want to be petty like that that's fine
that's okay we're all tied up you're
right and you got a wrong we're what
what
are we all tied up three questions left
okay we had a very popular
stunningly popular podcast until we took
on this
it's never been bigger this horrible
turn on this awful road
all right go ahead number five though
evidence is scant
adolf hitler is rumored to have had
which two
genital abnormalities okay so you have
to name
both if you can't yep and and if
one person gets only one and the other
person gets none they'll win
okay one undescended testicle
two missing testicle three
penile hypospadias which is the urethra
opens on the underside of the penis
or four micro penis okay i have the
answer to this and i pick
two or pick one you you pick two well
first of all
uh one ball is uh one one testicle
missing testicle missing testicle is uh
is
i mean soldiers sang songs about it
during world war ii probably propaganda
okay and
um then uh the other would be
uh the micropenis you got one right
you got the missing testicle micro penis
is incorrect
well i'm i'm coming i think it's the ure
i'm sorry
you guessed already and you got it you
got one right well i'm saying
micro micro penis is a relative term i
think compared to mine it would be a
micro penis
okay i'm gonna guess it's the urethra
one where the urethra is underneath
that's correct so you each get a point
here okay okay
it's all tied still this is exciting
tied conan
it's tied the big dick history quiz and
we're tied
so number six which classic rock star
had his big old yam
cast in plaster i got it okay jimi
hendrix
that's correct nice oh wow
how do you know that because i own it
[Laughter]
i uh i use it as a uh
it's a popsicle mold and yeah
no one knows i just distribute them
through the neighborhood no one knows
what they're really sucking on except
that it's delicious and cherry
what an awful awful road we've gone down
yeah okay
final question so uh sony you can tie it
up here or conan you can
take the victory i want this i want this
so bad
number seven errol flynn once used his
john thomas to do
what swat a fly play piano
open a door or hail a cab
me sona i know this one actually
play the piano that's correct uh
was that what you're gonna say yep no
you know what now you can lie
no that's a famous that's a well-known
story yeah he played a uh
a rag a baltimore rag he played with his
left hand
and his penis and apparently he did
three shows a night
oh kyle that's a true true true story
he was a session musician he appears on
a lot of
uh classic bing crosby songs just but
he's uncredited
you can just hear in the background the
piano which is lovely
lovely playing occasionally you hear a
swap
but other than that yeah
then the tie breaker here is i'm just
gonna see if you guys can guess
the answer to this question without
multiple choice what is
jonah falcon known for having a big
penis
would you care to elaborate large penis
that's ridiculous that's though that's
the point of this i
quit i know that's called so he's really
good at guessing i'm gonna need more
information you're gonna need more than
that
it he that person had the largest penis
no what could he do with it uh he made
puppets
penis puppets conan why don't you give
your answer sona seems to have given
hers and
and we'll see who gets you're going to
accept that as an answer i'm going to
i'm going to accept your answer and then
see who's the
most correct can i hear the name again
you're stalling jonah falcon
yeah who is jonah falcon don't you are
you googling
he is googling oh my god where are you
you're going to be disqualified
conan
he was a porn actor i know that because
you googled it
no i just happened to know that i i know
a lot about you so much
no that's ridiculous
that's ridiculous i didn't do anything i
didn't do anything
cheated in big dick history quiz i
didn't cheat i mean that's a new low
yeah that's worse than the flossing no
that's not true
why you say that i did something that's
wrong i didn't do anything that's wrong
okay the answer is sona gets the point
saying is
he claiming listen we all know that he's
the guy that who claimed in 1999 that he
had the largest penis in the world oh my
god at 13.5 inches that's just something
people know
oh my god really 13.4 he has the largest
penis on record apparently yeah but you
know what they found out later and this
is a true story that
they on closer examination he had
stapled four penises together
he also claims to be the son of john
holmes oh
yeah but it's the staples that gave it
away uh
you can't do that can i just say one
thing if you're out there and you would
like a larger penis and that's something
occasionally people wish for
stapling other penises to your penis is
not the way to go kids
it's just it doesn't work trust me and
uh
it's really no substitute for just
liking yourself as who you are
oh the more you know the more you know
that's my public service announcement
congratulations sona do you have two any
words wait i don't see
wait a minute first of all thank you so
much are you happy to win by big dicks
in history
what a shitty way to win sona what
congratulations uh it's that shitty
because you cheated that's
why i won no no no congratulations uh
you won the contest of bush v
gore congratulations president bush what
a weird way to win
win so bad you needed you needed the
supreme court
i.e uh gorly to step in and hand it to
you
uh despite the fact that i won
overwhelming in the popular vote how you
didn't win you
got your answers wrong and then you uh
granga okay now you're attacking my
heart
this concludes another episode of big
dick history i win the problem no
you don't come on default can you be a
grown-up you have children
you know what i love no one gets angrier
no one gets it more competitive and
angrier than sona it's true you got to
admit that
i get imagine oh my god i am so mad
right now
i'm mad and i won and that's the thing
that pisses me off oh you love this
you are the worst person i've ever met
he's playing piano
i'm playing piano
why can't you say congratulations on
your victory sona
sona to congratulate you on being
um declared the winner
because of a rule infrastructure you
cheated in multiple choice big dick
history is the saddest win
i can imagine and for me to congratulate
you on that to me is beyond the pale
i won't do it you've cheated it's okay
it's you your
victory has been ratified it's certified
you've won sauna
yeah you should feel good about it and i
don't i don't think trump and i'm biden
that's the way this is it's not gore
bush
still a lot of people but join us next
week for big bush history
is this really what the podcast is going
to become dicks and bush and
you snickering and sona laughing is that
i
i was trying to elevate the podcast no
you weren't making something i was
and try and make it something special
and then uh you guys come in with your
snickering
elementary school shenanigans i won't
have it
i won't have it if you won you'd be very
different right now
and that's that to me is my prize is
seeing how
angry you are and how you're attacking
my hard g's
because you're so mad you lost at this
quiz and i won
and that's something i'm gonna have
forever